[Music]
foreign
we're talking about is it's Joe Rogan
interviewing Steve Jobs and we'll sell
the background of how it works but
basically it's both it's all AI
generated and Joe Rogan is inter fake
Joe Rogan is interviewing fake Steve
Jobs and I got a little emotional
because like I like Steve I kind of like
Steve Jobs but I respect him a ton and
just hearing him talk about topics that
seemed modern I was like he's you know
he's back from the dead you know what I
mean I wouldn't exactly say he's one of
my heroes but he's someone I respect and
just I'm like oh my God the dead is
alive again and that was let's pull it
up so the way I think we should do this
episode is
I think we I think we focus on AI I
think we show some of the stuff that has
caught our attention so it's kind of a
show and tell so if you're if you listen
to the podcast I think you're going to
want to be on YouTube right now to
actually see this stuff and when you're
there you're gonna want to subscribe and
when you subscribe you're gonna want to
share tell your friend no okay but like
you do want to go to YouTube and just I
don't know go to YouTube and search my
first million and then then click the
channel this will be uh you know the AI
episode will be up there Ben is going to
screen share here and Ben do we have
audio let's play a little bit of the
intro well let me let me give the
background really quick so it's a
company called play.ht
um but and one of their side projects is
a thing called podcast.ai and basically
what they did was
they gave their AI algorithm or program
whatever you want to call it they gave
their program uh Steve Jobs's biography
uh which is and I think they actually
gave him one or two of his biographies
because there's two or two major ones
then they basically gave they gave the
program every single Steve Jobs
recording I think ever or any that they
could find on the internet along with
every Joe Rogan episode ever and they
made Joe Rogan interview Steve Jobs and
in the interview it's like 25 minutes
long they talk all about all types of
stuff but they say some amazing things
like Joe Rogan does the intro and he
goes like he teases out the who who it
is just like he does in real life he
goes what's up freak [__] which I
don't even think he says anymore but he
said that in all the early episodes he
goes what's up freak [__] uh today's
guest is someone who's incredibly smart
incredibly we should just play it right
let it let it insufferable well he says
insufferable which I thought was crazy
so go ahead this podcast is brought to
you by play dot HT
all content is generated by artificial
choice for this part listener discretion
is advised
hello freak [__] welcome to another
episode of the Bro jogan experience and
on this episode I welcome my friend
who's difficult to describe I'm
fascinated by him and I hope you'll be
too and he is weird and Brilliant and
sometimes totally insufferable but my
guest today has made some of the great
technological products of our age and
he's always pushing the envelope in
Innovation like for example with his
next computer he developed a new
programming language and operating
system and then he became even more
famous for making three applications for
that computer uh word processor
spreadsheet and an image editor that
just showed me that this dude was
brilliant had amazing taste and I would
just hope that I could be even like one
tenth of the genius that my friend today
is and I can't even say his name so yeah
so super psyched about having him in the
house today first time or yeah we've had
you on before but not for a long time
like Patrick Swayze and um Demi Moore
and ghost you're a memory from the past
[Laughter]
so without further Ado my friend who is
difficult to describe and wonderful and
I'm so grateful he came on the show
how's it going good to see you buddy
it's been a long time since I've been on
the show I've missed this it's always
fun wow like just pause there okay
so the things that like first the voice
quality the voice quality is incredible
like that sounds just like Joe Rogan it
sounds just like Steve Jobs it is it has
gotten so much better than like how this
used to be I remember like you know when
you had like the Garmin GPS in your car
and you could like choose the Morgan
Freeman Voice or whatever like any time
you'd have like this voice robot that I
was trying to say something new it
sounded totally computerized and this
doesn't so the voice quality is one
thing the fact that it kind of like
it makes more sense it makes more sense
than it should like he's doing an intro
it understands that he's teasing like
this my friend who's here today this
person's a genius but not saying who it
is and what it is right away that's like
a Showmanship thing that I thought was
like really interesting
um the back and forth banter like he
gives that long intro and then Steve
Jobs just kind of laughs
um like you would if you had sat down
for this kind of interview with Joe
Rogan I just thought that was incredible
the way it felt like a real conversation
and obviously there's some stuff that's
like you know he's talking about word
processors and documents and a little
too much like nobody would do that but
like
damn if 80 of that is not amazing and
the reason I felt emotional listening to
this was it's I felt both like in awe
but also scared because as I was
listening to this it I was agreeing with
what Steve says and uh what we'll do in
in a second uh Ben is fast forward like
maybe 10 minutes in and basically jobs
goes on this long rant about LSD saying
uh you know LSD changed my life and I
don't think it's for everyone but it
changed my life and it opened my mind up
and let me read all these books I never
previously would have read and he says
something like I don't I wouldn't take
LSD a bunch of times in a row because I
only needed it once or twice and it
opened my mind and it introduced me and
he goes in depth he goes it introduced
me to India and it's just he talks about
he's talking about God he's talking
about like all kinds of things that
you're like
it's not just like reading a Wikipedia
page you know what I mean like uh it's
very philosophical he's like when people
think about God they think about this
but to me it's and it's like well that's
a fully formed thought and philosophy
and like that sounds like something
somebody would say when they're having
like an in-depth podcast and not just
like I did this in 1979 in March when I
was living in Albuquerque and then in
1981 I once again it was wasn't that it
was like a very real sounding thing and
he has this amazing did you hear there's
this beautiful quote that he says and
basically the way that this company if
you ever listen to a bunch of Steve Jobs
interviews you'll notice that at points
it almost sounds like they're just
chopping up some of his clips and just
weaving them together because he has
talked about this before so I don't
actually know if he's ever said this
particular line before but he starts
talking about India and why he loves
like uh that part of the world and he
basically says like well it's so old and
it influenced the rest of society and he
goes there's an Indian epic that's ten
times as long as the Bible the Quran and
all these other things coming out of the
Odyssey yeah that's what he says yeah
he's like basically Indian history
influence the rest of the world and
there's an epic that's ten times as long
as all these other books and I just
thought that that's just like such an
interesting thing he does so he doesn't
say the name so it kind of leaves you
wanting there but he is talking about
the the Gita which is like is I think
that long it's like a 16 part
series or whatever it's like this really
really long thing I would bet that it
actually is multiples longer than the
Iliad and the Odyssey so I I feel so
interesting that he said that and this
is the point is that when he said that I
said I gotta find that book like he just
sold me on this book he influenced you
yeah the dead jobs influence me so Ben
click play just for like 30 seconds but
there is some kind of deeper meaning to
life and it can't just be something that
somebody made up because if it was it
wouldn't be compelling it would seem
contrived and everyone would see through
it so I think that the meaning and the
purpose is by the cosmos the nature of
the cosmos which is pretty bold thinking
I mean I don't know how else to put it
but it's not religious in the way people
usually talk about
taking LSD was a profound experience for
me LSD shows you that there's another
side to the coin and you can't remember
it when it wears off but you know it it
washes over you and tells you that
everything is connected you're not here
by accident you were put here for a
purpose and if you can figure out what
that is then you'll learn more about
yourself than anything else could it's
pretty intense so so that quote is a
real quote of his technology was a
profound experience one of the most
important things in my life it shows you
that there's another side of the coin
you can't remember it when it wears off
but you know it okay so that is like an
actual quote of his but it's weaved into
the conversation like there's a part in
the conversation where he where he says
he's talking about how he's a fan of Joe
Rogan he's like it's nice to just sit
back in the car and listen to you rant
and it's like okay so the first one
where he's the the LSD you know okay he
they just took a they just took you know
his Goodreads section or his quotes and
they're like okay cool he's he says
things like this
but where did how did it know to say to
Joe Rogan that I love to listen to your
podcast and the car just love to sit
back and listen to your rant where would
that have come from how how does that
happen that is there's like little
moments like that that are like
I just don't understand this technology
well enough to know how it could know to
say something like that in that moment
so the first half of the call he talks
all about India and these like kind of
platitude like life advice type of
things which were pretty amazing but
then the second half which bench just
started playing a little bit this he
talks about Google and they actually say
Yahoo Ron they call it yahoo uh they put
the emphasis on the wrong syllable but
they uh he's he like does all these like
says all these interesting quotes which
I actually think are things that he said
again in the past but he says stuff like
you know that's the problem I've always
had with Microsoft in many ways they're
smart people and they've done good work
but they've never had any tastes they've
never had any aesthetic taste and then
he goes on and he talks about Adobe and
he criticizes adobe's business model and
he goes uh Joe Rogan actually says what
would you do to fix Adobe and job says
well they've got 800 people working on
adobe's business model that's just way
too many people and the fact that they
charge just a little bit of money for a
small bits of the product it's like
buying a car but only getting part of
the car and having to pay more money to
get the rest of the engine and he like
says these criticisms about Adobe which
frankly have no idea if it's true but it
must have went on like a rant about this
you know in the past but and and then he
goes you know I had a lunch recently
with Bob whatever at Adobe he like says
their full name and he leads up this
part of adobe and he actually agreed to
me that they need to fix it and they're
working on fixing it and so anyway he
like actually gives
almost more advice and his opinions on
what I think are current events I'm not
well versed enough with Adobe but it
seems like current events it's pretty
magical
it's amazing yeah this basically was
like bring bring back someone from the
dead technology band do you have
anything to add your uh you're a history
guy what did this like do you have
anything that you felt when you when you
watched this
I really agree with Sam it made me oddly
emotional uh listening to it it also
scared me a little bit just because I
thought of the application of like what
if like you did this to my grandpa and
like what emotions would that bring back
and then that like frightened me of like
oh I don't know if that's a good thing
to be able to experience like
there's a representation my grandpa that
would feel like the real thing but isn't
right like where are these thoughts
coming from so it's equal parts like
really compelling really cool as like a
treat to be able to hear
well I think it's like a pretty accurate
representation of how Steve Jobs would
approach some of these things that are
happening today but then also just like
scary to realize but it's not really him
and what is it really well so let me
it's like a video right today you could
watch a home video and it's like you see
their face you hear their voice it's
captured a moment in time
to me this is an extension of that which
is like now it's gonna be somewhat
interactive that you can kind of
interact with these people or hear them
talk about new things uh and you know
that it's not like the real thing but
it's you know there's a black mirror
episode that's a lot like this where the
woman like uploads her boyfriend's
Consciousness to like you know this
robot she's kind of still dating him
even though uh you know he's gone but
like there's like the shadow of him that
like you know can can simulate him
um and I think I think there's more good
than bad
um Sam what do you want to say yeah so
let me add two points about why this is
going to give it even stranger well the
first point is is is almost scary so
basically in 1985 here this is a quote
from Steve Jobs he goes my hope is
someday when the next Aristotle is alive
we can capture the underlying world view
of that Aristotle in a computer and
someday some student will not be only be
able to read the words Aristotle wrote
but ask Aristotle a question and get an
answer and so Steve Jobs wrote that in
85 which is interesting now here's where
things get really interesting because
that's that's what he is what he's what
just happened what he just described is
what just happened to him it's magical
now here's where things are going to get
even more magical so play dot is it play
dot AI or play dot HD uh so uh part of
their website you can actually vote for
new episodes and some of the top
episodes that people have voted for is
Elon Musk interviewing uh Nikola Tesla
Kanye West and Bob Marley talking about
music Jesus interviews God and then I
believe there's Einstein and Buddha
having a conversation on science and
spirituality
um Trump interviews himself Trump
interviews himself there's Lex Friedman
interviewing Richard Feynman and then
there's uh Joe Rogan mediates peace
between Russia and U.S and that sounds
like a joke and it is a joke but it's
actually an interesting tool where
you're like well like let's hear Joe
Rogan alert let's see if Joe Rogan can
like bring together these two people
different people and hear each other's
perspective and we'll actually find out
where one another's coming from even if
it's make-believe and but it will still
be like maybe that is actually how they
feel and I could work through this
argument so that's why this stuff is
actually really really interesting and
Powerful
[Music]